but let me refresh you and take a little
recap of uh her past so we can talk
about the present and the future
almost 30 years ago a shocking incident
rocked the nation and dominated the news
in a sleepy virginia town lorena bobbitt
drew global attention when she
dismembered her husband john's private
part with a kitchen knife and threw it
out the car window claiming that he
sexually assaulted her john denied
abusing his wife and claimed he was an
abused husband ultimately lorena and
john were both charged with separate
crimes and then both acquitted
painted as a vengeful unhinged wife
lorena was a punchline on late night
shows and in headlines but maintained
that she was a terrified and trapped
young woman who endured years of alleged
domestic abuse and finally snapped today
lorena is an advocate for domestic abuse
survivors she founded the loreno gallow
foundation and creates safe spaces for
victims providing the support that she
says she needed lorena lives with her
long time partner and their daughter in
that same small virginia town where she
became infamous decades ago her story
lives on
[Applause]
thank you so much
thank you
i mean
i am freaking out to meet you i really
am
let me just say one of the things that i
really admire about you is
that
you
you dismembered your husband you chucked
it out the window you became like the
butt of jokes and when i see you hearing
and talking about it you have a sense of
humor
you are in on the joke
you allow people to giggle or be
uncomfortable and
and how do you manage that because i i
felt like a punchline too i was washed
up they're very different circumstances
but
i oddly uh relate a bit to the the
feelings of how do i ever
change this narrative about me
um well it's uh it's part of being human
to actually i look at my story as this
big tree that turns into branches yes we
talk about serious issues like domestic
abuse women's issues sexual assault
marital rape but also has a bizarre
twist into my own story which is the the
jokes and also the humor in it and i
said to myself well you know
i am human too and i have to learn to
live with and it's very sad not to
minimize the horrors that domestic
violence implicates on a person
because it really
drains you not only mentally
physically but psychologically
it really takes a big step onto women's
health and anybody who is a victim of
domestic abuse so to actually separate
myself from that and i became the punch
line of jokes and
people making all kinds of you know i
was basically like a cartoon character
um that you know people can't get away
from it so
i have to
take
my like my life back and basically turn
it around
and i said well it's it's part of humans
to joke about it's part of you know we
live with jokes all around
and and i have to understand that and
once you understand that part
that that comes with the nature of being
human then you are
you're basically it's part of the
healing process
it took a long time to actually
to get to where i am right now um it's
really it's really um
psychologically i mean i have i'm i was
lucky to have doctors to help me to go
through that process and you know to
start the healing process it took years
i mean i can laugh about a joke about it
now but uh really it's not a laughing
matter when you know the more we talk
and the more we get involved as an
advocate of domestic abuse sexual
assault and marital rape but um you i
have to create a balance and
when i am um i'm a keynote speaker for
colleges and
universities and when i do that
in order to for me to reach out and to
connect with the young generation you
have to basically introduce humor to it
and
my story has that and so basically this
is my platform and i utilize it to help
others to escape domestic abuse i
i love that i love that you are able to
humanize and humor i love
that you didn't run away you still live
in the small town you are a fierce
advocate for women
i mean that is the opposite of hiding
yes
there's so many layers
[Music]
you